Brush your teeth with nothing using colorless
flavorless Nihilist Toothpaste.
After eating a delicious bag of Chirps - the
protein-rich snack made out of beans, rice
and crickets.
Because it’s episode 46 of LÜT.
Wake up dressed in your bed with the wearable
futon air mattress and then strap on a pair
of RocketSkates.
Electric motorized skates that fit with almost
any shoe and allow you to go up to 12 MPH.
They’re controlled by tilting your feet
which means they’re hands free - great news
for anyone with giant lobster claws.
For hermit crabs looking to upgrade their
digs glassshell.com sells hand blown glass
shells - which are made to accommodate the
contours of a crab’s exoskelton-y body.
Snap together a Gummy Bear’s skeleton which
features detachable organs and a removable
skullcap to see the Gummy Bear brain.
Get grumpy thoughts out of your brain and
onto the pages of a grump notebook - a set
of three including daily disappointments,
things that annoy me and fresh rants.
To smell fresh and stay organized use Shower
Squids that hold shampoo and soap bottles
and for something smelly that holds pretty
much anything there’s orange cream scented
Duck Tape.
Tape together your own cardboard mask by following
instructions from Wintercroft.
Download a PDF of plans to transform recycled
boxes into a 3D cat, owl or Stormtrooper.
Then check out your new face in the Lucid
Mirror which contains a luminous 3D image
of celestial clouds hanging in the reflection.
Hang beer and save space in the fridge with
bottleLoft - the world’s first magnetic
bottle hanger for your fridge.
If you’re more of a milk drinker light up
your lactose using the glass of milk light
that perfectly pairs with midnight cookie
dunking sessions courtesy of Dunkin’ Buddy.
A device that saves dunked cookies from breaking
and getting lost in your cup.
Pizza Smelly Pen.
Pancakes Smelly Pen.
Cotton Candy Smelly Pen.
Ubi is an always-on voice-activated computer
that you simply plug in and talk to and it
does the following: Voice-enabled internet
search, speakerphone, home speaker system,
voice memos, virtual assistant, alarm clock,
intercom, baby monitor, thermostat, and noise
pollution monitor.
So for just one example if you’re baking
you can say, "OK Ubi..remind me in 20 minutes
to take the cake out of the oven” and Ubi
is pretty much like okay cool no problem human
I got this because I am Ubi.
And this is an Indiana Jones cat bridge.
Bridge your love of candy with your penchant
for mystery by getting a Japan Crate in the
mail.
Each month a box of assorted Japanese candies
show up on your doorstep that contains anything
from do-it-yourself sushi candy to vanilla
ice cream Kit Kats.
Then give yourself a break from cheap razors
and shave like a barber with the Beluga Razor.
A single edge exposed blade housed in premium
stainless steel that lets you shave like an
old school barber.
Shave yourself from Jaws with this Shark Repellent.
And start the countdown on your Time Bomb
Kitchen Timer because we’re almost ready
to ride off into the sunset on a motorized
monocycle - but make sure you remember that
zombies give the best free hugs.
And as always - thanks for watching!